he was the best high school player that
ever played in the state of indiana
he was the phenom in the basketball
crazed state
every gym we went into sold out news
helicopters landed on the baseball field
it was like going to a rock concert it
was damon bailey the minute he hit high
school ball
we'll never know how good damon might
have been
as the next great player
indiana in 1985 86 when damon bailey was
an eighth grader
bob knight went to watch him play
quite honestly that's probably when
everything kind of blew up to be
recognized nationally as an eighth
grader back you know
30 years ago it just didn't happen
we knew at a very early age he was a
good player he was a step ahead of
everybody on the floor
all of a sudden you know coach knight
walks into a gym
it was as if god had walked into the
building
i wrote about knight and how enamored he
was of damon
i guess that was the beginning of the
damon bailey phenomenon
back then just the thought of bob knight
going to see an 8th grader play
basketball was
mind-boggling people that aren't from
indiana
they don't get it people would not leave
damon alone
it was almost larry bird-like
people coming through picking grass out
of your yard as a kid
he had become a folk hero an adult would
come up to him and ask him for his
autograph
bob knight said damon was better at that
moment as an eighth grader
than any guard indiana had and when
you're built up the way he was built up
i imagine the pressure was immense
however
i don't think it ever affected him
nothing seemed to faze him
well damon bailey was certainly a phenom
there's no doubting that
the amazing part of it was when people
came to seem
they were rarely disappointed when they
left i'm the all-time leaning scorer in
the state of indiana with over 3000
points
gatorade indiana player of the year
four-time
all-state first team player mcdonald's
all-american
mr basketball in indiana nate smith high
school player of the year award
usa today's all decade player of the
year
i'm sure there are others but those are
the highlights
he was an extraordinary high school
player who
played his last high school game in the
hoosier dome the fabulous
bailey era closes on saturday set a
national high school
record for tennis 41 000 for the
championship game
the team we were playing was undefeated
he just wouldn't be denied
we were six down with two minutes to go
in the game all damen was about and all
he was concerned about was winning
damon proceeded to score the last 11
points of the game for us
we ended up winning by three all they
did was say
it's going to be him versus whomever and
he beat him
if hoosiers hadn't been made already he
could have made a movie out of that
and he is an honest-to-goodness hulk
hero
damon came in one day and said i i want
to go ahead and commit to iu
you go to india university at that
particular time you're going there to
win a national championship
when knight said that his career was a
disappointment i think that hurt him
and it was unfair damon bailey gave him
everything he possibly could as a player
but he got hurt and was really never the
same
there'll be a lot of people out there
that can question how good you were and
i think i've won more games at any
university than any player that's ever
played there
those are the ones that nobody's going
to take away from me
if given the opportunity in the right
situation he would have been a very good
player
and i don't think that ever really
happened for him he's not going to be in
the basketball hall of fame
but certainly anybody who calls him a
bus didn't watch him play
do i regret anything no being able to
make a lot of money because i can play
the game of basketball
i don't have to make decisions based on
whether i care whether i talk to you or
not
all the hoopla that he went through he
didn't ask for any of it
and i know it had to be hardpoint
the people that you know think i'm the
prodigy
you know they're probably wrong and the
people who think i'm a bust are probably
wrong as well